good evening everyone I'm Hugh Hewitt
and you're joining us at the Kirby
Center Hillsdale College's Washington
Lantern they are here and they have been
here for many years and I'm joined for
the seventh year in a row by Dr larion
president of Hillsdale College Kathleen
O'Toole Dr O'Toole is the assistant
Provost at Hillsdale College for K-12
education and annually We Gather in
December to do a teletown hall on
Reviving American classical K-12
education tonight we meet on a very
auspicious day doctor on it's the
birthday of one of the people about whom
you've spent most of your adult life
thinking yeah I met my wife studying
Winston Churchill in Oxford England and
today is his 148th birthday and what did
he have to say about education uh well
he uh Winston Churchill almost never
said anything that was not beautiful and
everything is he said about education
was and I'm going to read a little bit
uh this This concerns adult education
it's from 1953 the second time he was
prime minister and they started up adult
education never never done it before and
he held it up because what they wanted
to teach the education Ministry wanted
to teach adults was hobbies and new jobs
and stuff like that
and he made him change the curriculum
and here's what he says
how many must there be in Britain after
the Disturbed disturbance of two
destructive Wars who thirst in later
life to learn about the humanities the
history of their country the
philosophies of the human race and the
Arts and letters which sustained and are
born forward by the ever conquering
English language I guess that's a bit
chauvinistic but it's still concrete
this ranks in my opinion far above
science and Technical instruction which
however must be well sustained
the mental and moral Outlook of free men
studying the past with free Minds in
order to discern the future demands the
highest measures which are hard-pressed
finances can sustain in other words you
should teach kids what it is to be human
and if what you do instead is what we do
increasingly today in what average
totalitarian Society does which is try
to make them into something
we forget that they already are
something they are humans and Dr O'Toole
both you and Dr Ahn received your phds
from Claremont Graduate School studying
Aristotle with great students and
Scholars of Aristotle so they've been
thinking about education for a long time
what is classical education since that
is in your job title I want to know what
you think it is well it's a it's a it's
a kind of a newish name for something
that's very old classical education is
just liberal education it's well-rounded
education it's an education in all of
the subjects that someone ought to know
about in order to be able to understand
the human world and the natural world in
other words to just be able to make
sense of what it means to be a human
being it begins with the basics Reading
Writing arithmetic it includes
instruction and character because after
all you're not in school just to fill
your mind with a bunch of facts you're
in school to become the adult that
you're going to become and so we should
be talking about making good choices and
what it means to be a person of of
character of substance now each week Dr
iron and I talk on the Hillsdale
Dialogue on the radio about before we go
on to hear about our grandchildren
respectively we are observing education
as it unfolds in real time and what is
your two-year-old granddaughter taught
your doctor earn about education
well uh you know so alongside your boxer
I might yeah that's right you know so we
have dogs and boxers we've had them
forever my wife and me and uh you know
Dr O'Toole is the next Generation after
us and she has two children and they're
doing the same thing she did
and the boxers are doing the same thing
their predecessor boxer Did
children are learning to talk
nobody's teaching them they're just
listening to us intently and doing all
the work whereas the boxers also listen
to us intently and they never start
talking because they're stupid and
they're not and they're not they're good
dogs but they're not going to learn how
to talk they're not good dogs but
they're not human they don't they don't
have speech and they never will and so
what does the classical education do for
a two-year-old or a six-year-old or a
ten-year-old that public education that
we understand at large is the model in
America today doesn't do
well it teaches you to be yourself like
you said earlier your classical
education is not trying to turn you into
a particular thing it's trying to
identify what do you need to know
because you are human which you are
which everyone is
and then give you the tools that you
need in order to become a well-rounded
person who can then go on to do
something specific after that so it's
not Career Training
um and it's it's also not
um it's also not geared toward thinking
about the place that that a child is
going to fill in society later you know
that where it's not for the state it's
for the human being right and the
citizen which which means which is a
sort of larger more important role than
someone who is merely just filling a
filling a role for the stage so more
than a decade and a half ago a fellow
named Steve Barney who I've never met
you'll have to tell me about Mr Barney
came to you as the head of the college
and said we need to do something and so
what did he want done and what have you
done since then and what does Dr O'Toole
do in pursuit of whatever Dr Aaron and
Steve Barney discussed all those years
ago Steve Barney was the trustee of the
college he's retired from that now but
he's of extremely attractive character
uh he was in the financial world he made
some good money
but the big thing about him was he gets
worked up around High things and he
cries he cries all the time he's a
blubber baby
and one night in Florida at his home
he started thumping me on the chest and
pointing at a school across the street
from his house
and he said those kids over there are
not learning anything and they're losing
their opportunity for a good life and
then bump bump bump in my chest you have
to fix that
and I said well you know I've thought of
something and uh it uh see if if you
know some elements of Education the
first line of Aristotle's metaphysics is
the human being stretches himself out to
know
if you just around any kid and talk to
the kid they'll be extremely interested
unless they've been ruined by somebody
and and so they need to learn and what
do they need to learn
only human beings read write and compute
they are synonyms for human reason and
so they need to get good at those things
and then if once they get good at those
things as they get good at those things
the world is their oyster they can learn
anything and it's a wonder to behold as
a grandparent it's a one it's not so
wonderful as a parent they're your busy
but it's wonderful from from that
conversation with Steve Barney with Dr
Arn Dr O'Toole what has sprung what is
the uh the Hillsdale initiative today we
have the K-12 education office and
through the work of that office we teach
schools and prospective School Founders
how to bring this type of education to
their communities we have shepherded
along uh the founding of you know many
dozens of Charter and private schools
across the country we provide teacher
training for those schools we provide
curriculum we provide conferences for
their board members for their principals
and we're kind of of
helping local people come together and
then providing them with a network
through which they can learn with and
from each other and from the professors
at Hillsdale College about what
classical education is what should be
done in a K-12 school and how many of
them are there now when we talk about
public charter schools first of all what
is a charter school so charter school is
a public school
it's a it's a public school concept that
was started in the 90s and the idea was
we're going to have public schools
tuition free no admission requirements
and we're going to let those schools
innovate somehow do something different
than what the typical public school is
doing and the thought was we can learn
from that Innovation and so charter
schools are all over the country and
their their schools of choice meaning a
parent would decide to send their child
there they wouldn't be zoned for that
type of school the way that they would
for a public
and um charter schools are for all kinds
of specific types of curricula and
specific types of students High
achieving students students who are in
Dropout recovery programs they have all
kinds of charter schools our charter
schools are classical charter schools
and what they bring is a return to the
Excellence that was present in American
public education back to America's
public schools now you must be more
excited than any of the previous six
years because Arizona and West Virginia
have adopted Universal school choice
yeah and funding will now follow the
student yes and Arizona already has many
fine public Charters and I don't know if
you have an academy down there at
Hillsdale there are many excellent
charter schools in Arizona but this is
going to spread I spoke today with state
legislators from Iowa and they're super
majorities and they're going to do it
too and there are other schools you must
be so excited because this is like the
blossoming of a second golden era in
American Education well I hope so I mean
it's a it's a big school choice is a big
topic right now and what we saw in the
last election is that people are
resoundingly for school choice parents
are very concerned about what their
children are learning in schools what
they saw during covid was that
you know on those Zoom screens that
those poor kindergartners were forced to
look at the things that they expected
were happening in the classroom were
actually not happening at all and this
idea that the experts know what they're
doing suddenly seemed maybe not quite to
be true
uh meanwhile parents are forced to
homeschool you know themselves and they
start realizing wait a minute you know I
know a thing or two about this in our
schools we teach we teach that parents
are the primary educators of their
children and any parent knows you know
your kid better than anyone ever could
and you love your kid more than anyone
if in fact you are a parent you are a
homeschooler uh you just don't know
whether that you're a homeschooler you
read this book The Art of teaching by
Gilbert Hyatt and the one of the points
of it is that you
concerned with young people you are
teaching
even with adults right we're teaching
each other we're explaining things to
each other and so there is an art of
teaching and there is such a thing as a
classroom teacher who is dedicated to
that art and refining it but parents
know a thing or two about about their
kids and
um they should be given the opportunity
that charter schools give which is the
opportunity to decide is this curriculum
right for my child now I want to get two
important things done there are tens of
thousands of people listening to us and
the video this will be downloaded to
hillsdale.edu as soon as it's over but
if people want to contribute to a
one-for-one match which we do every year
the match amount has gone up to 1
million 650 000 so if anyone out there
wants to write a 1 650 000 check we will
match that tonight or you can call
Triple Eight four three seven thirty
nine forty one Triple Eight four three
seven thirty nine forty one
alternatively you can give at
hillsdale.edu Town Hall if you want want
to ask a question and there are tens of
thousands of people on the line you've
got to listen to this very close hit
star three you know asterisk on your
star three to get in the queue to ask a
question if you don't get through
tonight by the way just stay on the line
and leave it and they'll get back to you
but I do want to point out we're raising
money for this Initiative for all of
these schools 73 I believe spread across
the United States and more every day
Triple Eight four three seven thirty
nine forty one uh Dr Arn I want to ask
you about the 1776 curriculum before we
go to the phones and I know that we we
got to get to the phones in about one
minute what is the 1776 curriculum from
what did it grow and how important is it
in your view uh well it's a Civics
curriculum and what it grew from is
a few years of work that I've been
involved with by my teachers and others
who set out to recover the meaning of
America
and it got a name because Donald Trump
founded uh 1776 commission and I was the
chairman of that
and we wrote a paper about what kids
need to learn and how to teach them and
and that we've named the Civics section
of our curriculum and we have a complete
curriculum for every grade we've been
spending 10 years doing it but the
Civics part is called 1776 because
that's the year the country began and
and uh it's beautiful and it's people
always say
is it slanted toward America
or against it and the answer is no
tell what happened
America is a beautiful story it's a
human story of course there are failures
in it and so you have to talk about
those you have to explain them you have
to explain the standard by which you
understand them to be failures that
standard would be found in the
Declaration of Independence
so yeah it's a it's it's the best Civics
curriculum in the country I think
because it's written by people who have
deep deep knowledge of it and it's
tested in schools now for getting on for
a decade and it works I I just want it
to spread like Kudzu across the United
States because boy do we have a Civics
Gap I'm sure you don't have a Civic scap
in the Hillsdale charter schools and the
schools which you advise but boy that is
an important part of the tonight's
conversation okay lots of people want to
talk to us my first question is going to
be a a question live caller John
Cavalier in Miami Florida has a question
about how classical schools prepare
students for the future if you're in
line and you want to get a question and
hit star three to ask a question Joan
Cavalier in Miami Florida you're on the
line with Dr Ron and Dr O'Toole
hi there Dr Aaron in the group uh we I
appreciate the Hillsdale bulletins that
I get every month or so and I'm a a
person of classical education I went to
liberal arts college and I feel it helps
prepare you for love
uh that's just a general statement but
uh through my years I'm 80s too I have
seen the benefits of a classical
education well John you're not going to
get much of it
how do we help these kids that are
growing up now in the living in the
world to to survive financially because
that's what most of the emphasis is how
do I get a good job great question Dr
O'Toole in the course of learning a
classical education will you be equipped
to make a living there is no better
preparation for the necessities of life
and for the fundamental things of life
than than a classical education and
here's why if you if you go through the
curriculum at a Hillsdale classical
school you are going to be a reader in
most cases by the second half of
kindergarten you're going to study
mathematics in a way that gives you a
deep understanding of what's going on
when you do
simple calculations and then more
complex calculations you're not going to
be just copying the math
you're going to learn cursive you're
going to learn to form your thoughts
carefully both in speech and in writing
and it all culminates in a senior thesis
project where you take a look at the
things that you have studied
kindergarten through 12th grade and you
choose a book that teaches you about
teaches us about human nature and the
human good and you give a presentation
about that to your teachers to your
um to your fellow students to younger
students and so you culminate your
education teaching others and kind of
taking stock of all of the things that
you have learned I started one of these
schools and I have watched every student
who graduated from that school go
through that process and turn into the
type of person who is ready to
engage in the world you know confident
someone who knows themselves someone who
is curious about about the world and
able to continue learning even though
they're not in formal K-12 yeah I went
into a classical school not one of the
Hillsdale ones but in Arizona and the
12th graders were reading the brothers
karamata and they were having a
conversation and I thought these kids
are like 14th grade 16th grade and they
were seniors and it's because they had
learned year in and year out how to talk
and how to listen and doctor and I've
been with you in the cafeteria at
Hillsdale College where all of these
students are prepared to talk to listen
and to ask questions to me that is the
essence of a classical education to be
peripatetic and ready to learn at any
moment well the glory so you know I have
good things to say about Hillsdale
College and uh
if you come to visit the college come
just find out if I'm in town it's known
far in advance and I'll take you to the
dining hall and we'll sit down with a
bunch of them
and we'll beat the tar out of them it's
great fun and it's you know and like uh
and he'll still you'll be joshing around
and then somebody brings up a serious
subject and everybody sits up straight
now we're going to work and that it's
the time flies it's awesome yeah so
that's classical education though and
that is that's right you'll get hired in
fact we're in the heart of DC which is
slowly can I give the secret out that
you're taking over Washington DC with
classically educated kids I mean they're
everywhere they're they are like Kudzu
in Washington DC because they are of
great use to anyone who is interested in
governing why is that well you know if
you
we don't prepare anybody for a job
interview except we spend
all of elementary school and high school
doing that
and so the kids who graduated from
Hillsdale College I mean first of all
it's very difficult to get into
Hillsdale College these days
but they work really hard
they're expected to be virtuous people
that is courageous moderate
just
and wise
and they're supposed to practice those
things and they do and so you get a
chance to hire one of them and people
just marvel age I mean is that the case
in the in the charter schools as well Dr
O'Toole are they learning to be just and
wise and moderate and courageous yeah by
the time you've spent the high school
years alone you know at a minimum maybe
the entire K-12 sequence if you're lucky
you are a serious person you're a person
of substance you've thought about some
hard questions you've come to understand
yourself you've confronted your limits
you've made you know serious choices
based on
you know your your experience with a
talented faculty who's kind of
shepherding you along but also all of
these great works that we read which
teach you deep important things about
human life so if you've been successful
in these in one of these schools you are
ready for the world and a person who can
do a lot of good I have a lot of
questions but I want to go back to the
to the phone star three if you want to
get a call in jet gel is calling from
Lexington South Carolina you're on with
Dr O'Toole and Dr Arn please what's your
question
yes my question is what is the role of
the classroom teacher no matter the
grade level what do you imagine and see
the classroom teacher doing as
instruction is going on and as the
children are learning what what do you
see them doing
the teacher is leading
it is a teacher-led classroom sometimes
today you get this idea that um you know
teachers are there to kind of be the
coach on the side the guide on the side
they say you know well this in other
words the student is doing the learning
himself or herself usually from a
textbook or something and the teachers
they're like cheering them on no no if
you walk into the classroom at any of
our Affiliated schools the teacher will
be at the front of the room the teacher
will be leading a conversation and the
teacher if you look at that person's
resume they're someone who has
experienced this type of education
themselves they're deeply knowledgeable
about the subject that they're teaching
if when I was running a school and I
needed to hire a history teacher I would
look for history majors and then I would
look at their transcripts and I would
look at the courses they had taken and
their grades and those courses because
that is the first question do they know
do they know what they're going to be
teaching
and then the second question is
can they and do they want to explain it
to and do they have the talent to
explain it to young people those are the
types of people that we hire and what it
what it yields is a classroom where you
know it's very productive it's very
inspiring we're teaching Bell to Bell
um what's that mean meaning we the class
begins and we are working and then we
we're the teacher is still teaching
right at the very end there's not a lot
of group work there's not a lot of
projects there's not a lot of there's no
technology in the classroom except maybe
that the teacher is using to display
maps or things you know it's it's a it's
a productive classroom where students
are reading books and talking and taking
notes and learning real things
no technology in the classroom what an
antithetical statement to make oh my
gosh I sit here with my iPad but it's
it's important
um think about I mean we're all we're
all of the age where we can remember
what it was like to not have a cell
phone on us all the time
yes
but with you accepted you know you can
remember what your attention span was
like before you had the Apple watch and
all that stuff well think what it does
to Children right and we convince
ourselves that it's possible to you know
use the iPad to you know encount to help
the student encounter things that they
wouldn't normally encounter or whatever
listen I remember being in school I
teach students they do not do what
they're supposed to do on the iPad it's
a massive distraction and there's no
replacement when it comes to actually
learning meaning getting something in
your mind and letting it affect you
deeply there's no replacement for an
actual conversation with an actual human
being yeah uh and so we we don't do cell
phones we don't do iPads we don't do
unnecessary technology in the schools
and in many of them you know if the
students even have a cell phone on them
then it's taken away until the end of
the day because it's only going to be a
hindrance to the learning and to the
conversation that needs to be happening
doctor on a comment I I think that's so
great but if you have a contrary opinion
feel free to no no it uh you you learn
it's actually true that the learning is
in the student and the teacher leads
the student has to concentrate
for hours every day and you never learn
any important thing unless you're
straining to learn it and so you have to
focus yeah you see I have a point to
make which is have you ever seen an
athletic team train with cell phones on
them yeah have you ever seen a football
team or a bathroom you have great Sports
at Hillsdale College I assume you you go
and see as many did the wrestlers ever
have an iPhone with them when they're
being taught by their coach the answer
is no they're never ever engaged off to
feel great but I think what you made is
a point is that d-rigor for a Hillsdale
Affiliated school oh yeah I'm so glad to
hear that there's this book called It's
got it it's got a kind of intimidating
title for kids but it's called study is
hard work and it's about how to be a
student and the first chapter is called
learning to listen and it's a great book
that I always recommend to teachers
because it teaches you how to teach
study skills to the or you know the
habits of being a student
um and the point he makes is listening
is an active State and you have to it's
a muscle that you have to train you know
to sit through do you remember being in
college or high school and having to sit
through a 50-minute class where the
teacher was explaining something
complicated and
you know making a sustained argument
over time that takes work algebra
requires Transportation right that's why
the leader teacher is important because
when as you get your education you never
know the next step somebody has to show
it to you but then you have to do it
right and that means that uh you should
go to the kindergarten teacher at my
daughter's former school is Mrs Reardon
she's the greatest teacher I ever saw
and these kindergarteners coming you
know they're little wigglers right and
they they
just they're in a state of advanced
excitement for hours every day
they take a nap and they get a snack
right but they have to because they die
yeah and you know the energy level is
extraordinary you know and and the thing
is they are grasping things it's
extremely active
and they're doing it together right and
that's that's how we learn right I mean
but in Mrs raritan's class
you know you come in and you're taught
how to go to school that's what you
learn the late Mrs Drew did the same
with my children I marveled every day
how to sit how to raise hands and if you
smile before Christmas you'll cry
through the spring she smiles right away
I want to give the number out again if
you want to support this effort and it's
really the time this is the creation
moment everything has been primary to
this now the secondary moment is that
with Arizona and West Virginia and Iowa
soon to follow Ohio we soon to follow
with backpack funding classical schools
are going to are going to spring up
charter schools public schools but
they're going to be Charter Schools all
over the country and we need your help
we need you to make a donation Triple
Eight four three seven thirty nine forty
one Triple Eight four three seven thirty
nine forty one I'll do it again for the
Steelers fans Triple Eight four three
seven thirty nine forty one or go to
hillsdale.edu town hall one to one match
you get ten dollars ten dollars is
matched if you want to ask a question
pound uh star three star three Edward
Warnock from Morgan West Virginia hello
Edward you're on with Dr O'Toole and Dr
art
as a school former school superintendent
one of the concerns I always had was
Finding teachers that would be coming
from universities with some kind of
consistency and training that's a
problem I heard one of your panel
members saying when looking for a
history teacher they look for history
majors and we've had a lot of research
and a lot of universities have gone to
five-year programs whereby you must have
a degree an undergraduate degree in
science in math and history music art
and so forth and then move into the
educational realm but we need some kind
of a National Standard to make sure
pedagogically teachers are taught how to
teach and how the cognitive process
works in our society curriculum content
is important and we need that good
curriculum that you're talking about but
we need to train teachers better in the
learning process
phonetics and reading has to be taught
through phonetics it can't be done
through language
system or whole language approach let's
get let's get their input on that
opinions on yeah let's go to that
because I have a very strong opinion but
I'm uneducated on this uh Dr Arn first
and then Dr O'Toole how about teachers
do they have to be trained
uh well they they have to learn uh they
have to I mean first of all
if you have learned a thing in principle
you can teach it now the gentleman is
very right
the first year is the devil
and it's better if you've got some
instruction just how to do that right
how to run the classroom how to keep the
kids interested but good teachers for
some reason well it's it's not even a
mystery uh Hillsdale kids you know
they're they're to top college hard to
get in everybody works hard right they
nearly die their first year of teaching
after that it's easier it's always hard
but it's easier right because you get
some skill at that job and that is a job
and and you know I mean
we love we love to beckon people to
remember the great teachers they've had
remember for a minute the bad ones
you've had
let's go on the former I I can remember
my Latin teacher in ninth grade walking
in lift throwing his chalk up and then
uh doing declension
uses and I just remember that because he
just did it with authority
with a lot he was alive to it and I
don't know that you can put that in by
education can you Dr O'Toole I mean
isn't that boring you've got to you've
got to
have the inclination and the ability to
teach but
the experience of teaching in year one
is very difficult and it's helpful if
you have some training and so we provide
that when we work with a school we we do
a two-week in service for the school in
its first year to get those teachers up
to speed and then they come to Hillsdale
and we go to them for regular
conferences regular professional
development to help them
you know refine the the craft of
teaching and specifically the teaching
this curriculum I'm so glad you used
that word I was going about to use that
word it's a craft and every craft can be
improved upon no matter the skill level
that you have by repetition until your
skills begin to decline and that's with
a teacher is awfully late in life they
can teach into a long period of life
let's go back to the to the phones again
to donate to this effort Triple Eight
four three seven thirty nine forty one
go to hillsdale.edu town hall as well
one for one match I want to remind
everyone if we don't get to you and
there are lots of either tens of
thousands of you listening stay on the
line at the end leave your question
people will be back to you more than 70
charter schools with 15 000 K-12
students in 27 States it's going to be
double that next year thanks to your
generosity I'm sure Pamela Brigman from
Saint Petersburg Florida has a question
about curriculum in public schools
Pamela you're on with Dr O'Toole and Dr
Arn
oh thank you so much for taking my
question I really appreciate it I am not
a teacher I am 61 years old and a
retired nurse in oncology but my best
friend is a ninth grade English teacher
at a public school about three hours uh
east of me she's teaching honors English
and
um has been a teacher for a long time
and in that class at her school they
they are teaching uh critical race
Theory
and my friend was shocked because you
know desantes Governor DeSantis made a
law that no critical race Theory would
be taught in any Florida public school
but it is being taught and my friend was
told by the principal you will not
assign none of those teachers are
allowed to sign homework that the the
they can only read certain things and
she's just mortified and she hates it
but she needs a job and she doesn't know
what to do do you call the you know
attorney general in the state how do you
you report it I mean you know Dr O'Toole
what do you do completely disrespectful
yeah take their cell phones and they
record her
yeah that is a hostile environment and
it's a difficult but it's the reality
for many public school teachers isn't it
I think I think the public school system
is full of of teachers like your friend
who are you know they got into it
because they really cared about kids
maybe they had a wonderful teacher or a
wonderful experience in college and they
thought I love learning I want to teach
this thing that I truly love and
understand to more kids and I think
Public School teachers are feeling
frustrated and confined by high-stakes
standardized testing by pay raises
attached to their children's their
students performance on these tests they
they feel like they have to teach only
to the test and then they feel like
curriculum is handed down to them and
curriculum is changed year after year
after year
uh you know and so there's not a chance
for them to really become expert at it
before the the game has changed on them
teachers in Hillsdale schools are given
women a tried and true curriculum that
does not change and doesn't need to
change because we're confident in it
it's the great works of the western
tradition
and it's the best way to teach
mathematics and the best way to teach
phonics and if you teach in an
environment like that you can spend
10 years 20 years of your life reading
9th grade literature in our school would
be Homer's Iliad Odyssey Shakespeare's
Roman plays you can read those over and
over again happily for 10 years and
learn more from it yourself and become
better at teaching it well Dr this is
not a political show we are not a
political process but I would point out
Mike Pompeo today tweeted out the number
one threat to the United States is not
Chinese Communist party it's not Iran
it's Randy Weingarten and she took up
the challenge now I don't want you to
comment on on the former Secretary of
State's Throwdown or her response but
that clearly goes to your off-made point
that fundamental things are afoot there
is a collision underway look if you're
the word education means leading forth
and I didn't know that uh yeah so one of
the things that uh yeah stick with me
all right okay you learn something new
every year he's waiting for it
if uh
uh
what we say to the kids
is what we say to the Future
and that is deeply controversial and the
the the the the
last caller the last two have both been
spectacular by the way thank you both
um
she's saying that this woman is being
driven by a centralized
you know we want we're turning America
into a controlled experiment
and and that means that experts starting
with Harvard and going on down lord
Hewitt Harvard
um I had Harvey Mansfield so it didn't
hurt
everything is centralized right but the
truth of the matter is I I read that
quote from Winston Churchill everybody
should glory in the greatest things
written and said down through time
and the thing about critical race theory
is that's all just right now right you
never you never get a chance to step
outside it's like you're being educated
by the New York Times
and that's not the way to be educated if
you get if you study the great works
I mean Socrates had a student in Plato
Socrates didn't write anything Plato had
a student in Aristotle now those two
guys are as good as there ever was
book one
chapter 3
of Aristotle's ethics takes up an issue
with Plato his teacher
right and that means that when you read
these great works you'll look at things
from every possible point of view
in a way that encourages you to try to
figure them out and you will break it
down and you will figure it out which is
why you are educated uh let's go back to
the phones because we're in Wichita
Kansas I talked to your legislator this
morning Clint Davis or Davis Clint I
think it's Clint Davis uh calling us you
are on the line remember press star
three to ask a question live caller
Clint Davis welcome you're on the doctor
I told him Dr art
the question I have is um we have three
uh
conservative uh school board members
right now in this I run and get elected
and maybe get another one we may have we
may have a majority four or five uh and
so what I would like to know is how can
you help a public school board Implement
a Hillsdale American K-12 educational
system select a superintendent Co hire
and to train teachers and Implement an
excellent cooker curriculum or is it
possible boy this is a big question we
can help we can help we're helping a
public school district in Idaho right
now
the first thing we can do without any
further Ado is point you to the 1776
curriculum it's
um you know Decades of scholarship on
American history and civics
put into lesson plans and primary source
documents and Sample tests and quizzes
for K-12 students to study American
history and then later government and
Civics and you can download that right
now and your District can adopt that and
use that for the teachers the teachers I
think will love it it gives them the
autonomy that that they should want and
I think do want when they're excellent
teachers it gives them guidelines not a
script to read and all of the things
that they need to craft amazing lesson
plans are right then and there Brent I
want to add go fast go far and I want to
ask Dr Arn about the superintendent
question because this is actually coming
up all across the United States for a
very very important changes have been
made at the school district level voters
have demanded change so the first thing
you have to do is dismiss a
superintendent and find a new one where
do you find the new one well it's uh you
know just remember
uh
we think too much of expertise yes more
important than expertise is want to
right so anybody who's got a knack for
running a railroad and an in an
education
can do that job you know we have to get
back to the idea by the way that anybody
can do anything they want to do
you know because that's America right
and and you know if it's beyond them
then they probably won't want to do it
for very long but not very many things
are Beyond people I have a suggestion
and I'm not the educator here the
doctors are the educator but the
fetching misses Hewitt my wonderful wife
of 40 years went to Fallbrook Unified
High School which was operated by the
Marine Corps Colonel and which had three
Marine Corps Colonels on the staff they
had no discipline problems the Marine
Corps Colonels were in a classroom and
they knew how to run because they'd run
platoons in combat and they had to get
accredited now they wouldn't have had to
get a credit in the 70s what do you
think about people who are making
transitions Dr O'Toole from other fields
to go and teach do they need Masters do
they need phds to be teachers and
superintendents or can they need to know
the subject they're going to teach and
they have to love kids and they have to
be able to explain well to kids to be a
superintendent though I was getting
specifically I think your superintendent
is the principal in the district who the
teachers love the most I think that's
the danger of the education bureaucracy
is that we get we get far we get further
and further move from the classroom
right and the the people at the top we
have the statistics actually on the rise
of of
um
hiring of non-teacher and non-principal
education personnel and it's the numbers
are staggering I'll summarize the
numbers I have memorized since 2000
number of students students in public
schools have grown seven and a half
percent number of teachers in public
schools has grown eight percent a number
of Administrators in public schools have
grown 92 percent so that's so who are
those people right who are those those
are those people who are telling the
principles you know this is the report
that's due you need to do this data
crunching you do this boom boom boom
boom boom right and so the the job of
the principle The Challenge of the
principle is to Mentor the teachers and
to bring the faculty together and to
ensure that the curriculum is being you
know happening and it's alive in the
classroom and everything's lined up
properly and the teachers are masters of
their craft and you in other words the
principal should be focused on the
classroom so the superintendent should
be the teacher the principal about whom
the teachers have the highest regard yes
because
because if if you if you can get people
at the top who are who know what it is
to be a teacher which a lot of them
don't
uh and you can
you know get them so that they're
pointing their attention down into the
classroom and helping the people in the
classroom do their work rather than fill
out whatever report that everyone up
here is caring about then we can start
retaining better teachers attracting
better teachers and you know actually
get some traction going you need to get
so
as you know Winston Churchill was very
great man
and he wrote an aphorism that's the best
management advice I've ever read uh I
was asked this by an MBA on the search
committee to be the president of
Hillsdale College and I have in round
number 700 employees
do I do their work for them
I just remember this it is the Safeguard
and the glory of mankind that it is easy
to lead and hard to drive
yeah so so when I hire somebody
I I was asked the same question
I always work around to tell me what do
you love
what what drives you right and that they
people always answer that question with
enthusiasm and for the most part
accurately how could I have no easy to
lead and hard to drive when did he say
that and what the context and how come
he never told me that before well that's
in an essay that we're going to read on
the Hugh Hewitt Show okay your education
is taking a long time
we'll get there it's uh no it's in Mass
effects in Modern Life and it's just I
you know I had this MBA guy who was on
the search committee to hire the
president of Hillsdale College which I
had decided I might try to do
and he said how did you learn how to
manage
and I said well various ways one of them
doesn't matter and he said what I said
Peter Drucker used to be my landlord
he's he's the inventor of modernity and
you know he's a wonderful man I just
never studied with him I just knew him
well for a long time wow he said I said
no that doesn't matter
I said I learned to do it by making
mistakes and not making them again if I
couldn't if I could
but then also Winston Churchill
summarize the whole thing and it is the
whole thing by the way
everybody in life has a station
and that's their station
at Hillsdale College my station is to
teach which I teach just like the rest
of them and they're my classrooms and I
run them
but my station is to supervise
right which is not the same thing as
doing the work that's leading and it's
mostly helping people to do their job
when they need it and that and then if
you if you do things like like here's
the thing that happens all the time uh
if you write me a letter even a dirty
letter
it will be opened by a student I get
hundreds of letters a week you know and
it'll be opened by a student and they'll
read it first and they'll decide what to
do with it
and they compose answers if somebody I
don't know I look at them anyway uh once
in a while they'll come in and say
how do you want me to do this
and I always say successfully and they
and they look up a minute and they say
they realize
this is your job if you have a specific
question I will help but
I don't know how to do it you're going
to have to do it you see that's and
teaching is the same right like beloved
bosses
are people who admire the people who
work for them and help them and help
them expect them to do their children I
want them to stay and want them to
actually rise I I need to go to
Cincinnati by the way hit star three to
ask a question the phone number to call
to make a donation which will be matched
dollar per dollar Triple Eight four
three seven thirty nine forty one or you
can go online to hillsdale.edu town hall
at Triple Eight four three seven thirty
nine forty one or hillsdale.edu town
hall I have to take this question
because it's from Cincinnati Ohio which
is almost in Ohio Megan Fallen is
calling in good evening Megan we're
going to make we're going to consider
Cincinnati part of the Buckeye state for
this purposes
well you know what I went to college in
Kentucky so it would be okay with me if
you pushed me a little further south
there you go um I have two high
schoolers and I cannot tell you how
excited I am that Cincinnati
um is opening or just opened this past
school year I've Cincinnati Classical
Academy
um I had called for several years kind
of requesting one and I wasn't the only
parent locally really looking to open
one in Cincinnati unfortunately it was
not open in time to service my kids
considering I have a ninth grader and an
11th grader for years and years
obviously actually before my kids were
even in school I've been doing what I
considered homeschooling we called it
after schooling where I would try to
supplement what I thought my kids
weren't getting in their education and
so my question is what can parents like
me who don't have access my kids are a
little bit old on the older side didn't
have access to a Classical Academy
education I did what I could to
supplement what other resources before I
turned them loose on the world can I do
as a parent to supplement their
education and give them what they need
to be successful in college but most
importantly to be successful adults well
there's a ton of stuff if you go to K-12
at home K12
athome.hillsdale.edu you'll see that
we're putting things there for parents
like you these are you know parents who
can't get their children into a
classical school or parents who want to
homeschool and need resources you'll see
book lists lists of books that we read
in the curriculum you'll see videos
about how to teach specific Topics in
the curriculum you can download the
entire 1776 curriculum and get the
entire history and Civic sequence which
goes all the way up through high school
that would be a great thing to do for
your kids
what's that web address again Dr O'Toole
it's K12 K12 at home
a-t-h-o-m-e dot hillsdale.edu K-12 at
home Dot hillsdale.edu.edu and that's
our resources for parents of children in
school or homeschooling fabulous answer
I'm going to put videos there right
there are videos there also I think you
should offer this woman a job I think so
too she's gone now send me an email the
next person in line hits star three to
ask a question Hans Hans Cuke in Orlando
I hope I'm saying Cuke correctly Hans
welcome you're on with Dr R and Dr
O'Toole
well thank you
um quick question for the Hillsdale
Charter Schools how are teachers
evaluated how do you do that oh that's
great it's a great question a lot
depends on teacher evaluations so the
first thing is it's frequent frequent
observations right as the as the
principal you are in the hallways all
day every day stopping in on classes and
checking in on the teachers
uh you need to know what's going on in
your school and what's going on in your
school is going on in classrooms not on
spreadsheets do you teach teachers not
to resent that but to welcome it well if
you yeah we teach the yeah yes we do
um and it's it's a little scary at first
being observed but after a while the
teachers really learn to appreciate it
because they think of teaching as a
craft and it's helpful to have another
adult just take a look for 30 minutes
and say oh you know by the way you know
your handwriting was a little smaller it
would have been helpful if you had put
an outline of what you were talking
about on the left side of the board
before you started lecture you have to
believe you're not there to hurt them
right they have to believe you know they
have to think of you as a fan
who also wants to get better
you see my experiences with ABA
accreditors and they are there for an
ideological agenda it's all a community
so the community it's a they're
Regulators they are Regulators my people
are Regulators your people are coaches
resist every impulse to be a regulator
right like at Hillsdale College we don't
like rules every year I repeal more
rules than we make we used to have 130
pages of student rules now we have 17
rules they take up a page and a quarter
and I'm working on getting them down to
a page because goals are the thing
right and if they don't accept the goals
you can't work with them but if you get
the goals clear then when you go in into
their classroom you're there to help
them reach the goals okay but I want to
go back to Hans because he said that's
part one observe what's part two
frequently and then the the criteria
that you're using for for observing are
common sense criteria so the first
question that I used to ask when I was
observing teachers is who's in charge
when you walk into the classroom who's
in charge it's either the students or
the teacher if it's the students it's
not good it should be the teacher so
that's the first thing as a teacher you
should be in charge was the was it clear
what the teacher was trying to teach yes
or no
was the teacher effective at teaching
what he or she was trying to teach yes
or no
do you teach principles this she gather
them together this is what we do in our
principal training yeah and it's
teachers love it right because it's the
same criteria for every teacher in
advance that's a breath of fresh air
it's not
it's clear it's common sense it's easy
to do and it's obviously what you should
be doing if you are a if you are a
teacher and then the principal is the
one who's helping everyone do a great
job at the thing that they've chosen to
do because they love it and the
relationship between the principal and
the faculty as a whole is collegial and
friendly and we're all boosting each
other up that's what you get in the best
ones uh Charlotte is our next live
caller again hit pound three or oh she
excuse me star three to ask a question
to make a donation Triple Eight four
three seven thirty nine forty one two
tens of thousands of people are
listening to the telott town hall
tonight or watching it later in the day
that phone number will be available
Triple Eight four three seven thirty
nine forty one hello Charlotte you're on
with Dr Ahn and Dr O'Toole
hi
um thanks for taking my call I had a
question
um I'm currently in college to um be an
elementary ed teacher
and uh I was wondering what your Charter
Schools do when there are kids in the
class in like the general class who have
like
learning disabilities or their like
English language Learners
um just not your
like who needs extra support but they're
still in the typical class yeah Charter
Charter Schools do the same thing
provide the same services for students
on 504s and IEPs and students with who
are learning English I don't know what a
504 those are learning plans for
students with disabilities okay an
individual assessment plan education
plan right IEP is an individualized
education plan so those are those are
the plans that you have if you have a
learning disability and it could be a
mild learning disability or a more
severe learning disability Charter
Schools serve all of those students
along with regular education students we
call them now we're
we think that teaching is really
important and in my experience the best
special education teachers are the best
teachers they're really really
thoughtful about exactly how something
needs to be taught to this student and
what the mind of the student needs to be
able to do in order to grasp it and
they're the type of people who can see
oh this child has a learning disability
in mathematics for example and I can
look at the the child's report and I can
judge from that report and from working
with the child exactly how that child
can be taught
when special education goes well as it
does in our schools it's just excellent
teaching
and the special education teachers
actually have a lot to teach
regular education teachers about you
know the brain and about the way that
these different disabilities work and so
yes these are schools for everyone I'm
so glad you said that now we are all
Californians here in lesser or larger
part doctor on Dr O'Toole and me so I
like getting Nancy cherny calling from
Novato California though I don't know
where Novato is a question about
California specific hello Nancy you're
on with Dr O'Toole and Dr Arn
uh it's a great honor to be talking with
all of you
um so I live in Marin County which is an
extremely liberal part of an extremely
liberal State and charter schools are
under attack in California they don't
want to really let more charter schools
into California but as a concerned
citizen whose child has already
graduated
from college and all of that how can we
as concerned citizens help our public
school principals
superintendents and teachers to grab
onto and teach the curriculum of
Hillsdale when they're being forced to
do some version of CRT and some version
of Common Core which are both attacking
our California public schools in math
yeah well I think your School Board
elections are going to be really
important
um I think that I think that people need
to remember that
teaching what to teach and how to teach
it are essential questions and the
answer to those questions is not as you
say it's not rocket science I think we
we know what the best things to study in
K-12 are that's a limited number of
years you should study the best things
we should not be using those years to
experiment with the latest and greatest
and
most politicized stuff so yeah I think I
think my translation of your question is
what do I do to help the locals and it's
to give them courage is to encourage
them I mean you go to them and say I
will support you I will come to your
meetings I will speak on your behalf I
will not be angry I will be supportive
of any attempt to embrace classical
education and for those who are inclined
to run for school board Dr earn they
ought to yeah yeah you should so we we
have a charter school in California in
Orange County it's not the same thing as
Novato but it's
not as conservative as it used to be no
it's getting there uh it uh they you
know it
I I think the key to American politics
speaking as a political scientist for a
minute
is what do people love the most
uh they love their families and they
love their work
especially in their families they love
their children
and so their battles going on all over
the country who owns the children
and so you're just going to have to take
that battle to School Board elections
and you know I mean it's you know the
facts about children are very simple to
understand human babies take a very long
time to grow up and you get more after
they do
and and then somebody's got to care for
them
and there's a natural love of the people
who conceive and bear them for the child
that has to be the staple and that means
no human being gets to own any other
human being ever but uh parents are
appointed by nature to look after the
children while they're minors they
should have the whip hand and my
admonition to every school board member
is not to go to your National
Association of school board members
conference and not to be led by your
superintendent of schools and not to be
given Direction but to remember who sent
you and who elected you and what you ran
on because this new wave of Sioux school
board members ought to be calling it
they ought to be besieging you Dr
O'Toole for help because they're not
they're being elected to change things
right they're being elected to change it
Jamie Britton has a question about State
Standards again press star three to ask
a question Jamie you're on with Dr
O'Toole and Dr Arn
hi
um this you touched on this a little bit
ago but like the current School charter
schools that you have now
how are they teaching classically and
also satisfying state standards the
state standards on at complete odds with
a classical education
they're teaching CRT and SEL and those
kind of things
well by definition the state standards
are General
and the curriculum that we provide and
the lesson plans that the teachers put
together because of the curriculum that
we provide is specific
we don't go into a state where the
standards prevent us from doing the
mission so we do an alignment and we we
take stock of it and we have not found a
state in which it is not possible to
teach this curriculum and remain
faithful to the law which is what when
you're in 2017 States 27 States that's
right
um I can speak from experience I I
started a school in Texas
the Texas standards were at the time and
I think still are pretty good
um but they don't they don't tell you
what to say in the classroom they tell
you what students need to be able to do
at the end of your of your year with
them and so there's a lot that the that
the standards don't ask and standards by
definition are uh minimum standards
right they because they have to apply to
every public school in the state
we find that in our schools we easily
meet and exceed the standards we don't
just teach what's required by law we do
a lot more on top how does it relate to
Common Core many years ago that was a
flash topic it was sort of the beginning
volley in the education conflict in the
United States was the introduction of
Common Core which was widely and quickly
understood to be indoctrination and bad
teaching so how does the classical
standard comport with the common common
core is not great and the standards are
weak but because our curriculum is so
much stronger and more robust and more
deep than those standards we do operate
in many common core States we just don't
merely do that I see so that's the the
floor let me uh we have a we have many
wise people at Hillsdale College and one
of them is wise about that very subject
you're asking his name is Dan Copeland
and he's the dean of our new masters of
classical education program
some sample State Standards there's
nothing wrong with state standards they
should be General and achievement
oriented that is to say what should the
student be able to do
he wrote when Mike Pence was governor of
Indiana
uh he wrote for Mike Pence
standards for four grades and they took
up four pages
yeah and you know if if the kids could
do almost all of the things on those
four cages Pages they'd be well educated
so he translates the edge of crat
bureaucrates into Simplicity you know
and that's and another thing is you no
no rules right I hate rules it's a bad
idea medicine writes if the laws laws
are so voluminous and changeable that no
one can remember what they are
then no matter how they're made they're
not laws right and so you know it's got
to be
a six inch Fat three ring binder or it's
not serious nobody nobody does things
like that nobody no nobody Democrats do
what is this Masters in classical
education of which you speak well we you
know we've got this crazy thing going on
right we uh we don't take any money from
the government so we never get any money
from these charter schools and we're
doing several million I'm glad you made
that point I was supposed to make that
point thank you you do not have a
relationship financially with these
schools several what we do we spend a
lot of money on it yeah you do
we uh we we you know we spend several
million dollars a year doing this thank
you the great people who make that
possible
and and
we we uh so and we're good partners
right because
we we only want them to be great
uh we don't have the power to tell them
what to do
we make a contract with them
we will spend time and money on you and
give you this curriculum where you can
have it for free without a contract
and we will help you do it but you have
to agree to try to do it
and that way everybody in the
relationship is a volunteer
and you know come come to the campus in
the summer there are hundreds of
teachers all summer long I'm never
invited to Hillsdale in the summer I'm
only invited the depth of winter as you
know that's because we're worried about
your character but tell me about this
Masters in classical education oh yeah
okay so now you know we need people to
run schools yes I was wondering if
that's it and uh and so what are they
learning
uh
they're learning the stuff we're talking
about tonight
and they're getting you know you know
I'm
I don't have any training in managing
right and I'm I'm glad
uh the great Peter Drucker was my
landlord but I studied the things he
studied I knew him pretty well right I
said to him once management by objective
which is a summary of everything in
invented I said that sounds like
Aristotle to me and he put his finger to
his lips and went
I'm going to sh everyone now because I
want to get to more calls Rowan Rowan
wallboard I'm sorry I butchered that as
a question about what to do to help his
14 grandchildren he's lapped us combined
so that's that's a quite a good
R Wayne is that what it is
yes it was wait I go by my middle name
and I'm here in Colorado with 14
grandkids in London in Virginia and in
the state of Pennsylvania but my home
was Colorado I'll get them out of
Pennsylvania but your question is go
ahead
what can a grandparent do in attending
school board meetings where they do not
have a student affect possibly the
outcome of the school board criteria to
include Hillsdale College curriculum
thank you Hillsdale College for this
telemarketing ah thank you uh the uh so
first of all several states have adopted
our curriculum substantially
substantially I heard Ron DeSantis say
in a public speech the other day that
Florida had and we've been working with
them you know and we will help any state
or District that wants
and and you know it's it you know right
now South Dakota is evaluating you know
it's very controversial
uh I talked to the governor whom I know
pretty well Christy no she's a good
woman
and she said uh but what do we do about
the Native Americans and their special
needs and I said
you know I happen to have read a book
about the Native Americans in
South Dakota it's a noble and wonderful
story tell that a tragic story too tell
that story that's all you do in in
school I mean after you learn reading
and writing arithmetic uh Dr O'Toole
said it earlier then there are two
things you need to know you need to know
the story of the human
so the human story and you need the
story of the natural world and those
stories are things that are exist right
you don't make them up
and so in South Dakota
I mean look up a a man a Comanche chief
the Comanche were very tough very tough
and they ruled a significant part of the
United States for a long time with a
population of 30 000 people
and and quanta
who was half white
was the last great Chief and he's the
one who made the peace
and then he died as a real estate
developer in Colorado and it's a
wonderful story it's a great story and
he and he never he he he never shed his
Comanche roots
there are great stories to be there are
great novels we were in Michael Punky
writes great novel called Ridgeline
about the Battle Before the Battle of
Little Bighorn my suggestion to our
grandfather is do not go to a public
meeting and make a speech instead call a
school board member and ask for an
appointment in their office and bring
along the 1776 curriculum and say to
them are you aware that this group of
pioneers are up there in Michigan and
then if the school board member calls
you Dr O'Toole what will you talk to
them about we'll offer any help that we
can offer in the form of curriculum in
the form of teacher training you know I
have neglected Dimension which is a real
problem a book that we have for any
teacher that explains the principles of
classical pedagogy and it's a helpful
resource for these districts too it's
called tried and true the author is Dan
Copeland it just came out he's the head
of our education department in this
graduate school we've been telling you
about and it's a really handy guide for
anyone who is a teacher this is the kind
of thing that a dish strict would find
helpful tried and true tried and true a
primer on sound pedagogy
K-12 uh at yep found it on our website
k12.hillsdale.edu and uh it's a it's a
small accessible easy book that will
remind you
what the principles of good teaching are
and that you can do it if you are a
homeschool parent or a classroom teacher
we have time for one more uh question I
do want to remind people if you've been
inspired tonight to take action begin
with a contribution because it'll be
matched one for one by calling Triple
Eight four three seven thirty nine forty
one go online at
hillsdale.edu Town Hall I'll tell you
that one more time and if you have not
been gotten to stay on the line please
this is not a live caller this is a
question from Jim messite in Colorado
Spring who wanted to know why did we
change our teaching methods in the
country and quit teaching certain things
doctor you're familiar with this long
battle it goes back to the beginning of
the last century well we have
revolutionized our country
in the name of science science means
Techni art making things it doesn't mean
knowing things which is the original
meaning and so what we think now is that
only experts can do the best job and we
have built you know in for most of
American History the government of the
United States state federal and local
didn't consume as much as 10 percent of
the gross domestic product now it's over
50 percent
for most American history what was
consumed was consumed mostly in
localities now it's centralized right we
have centralized the administration of
our country and I've been saying in
various ways and I'll say it again if
you want to know how to run a railroad
the employees are going to run the
railroad you're just going to help them
right and and so
it's it's the promise of America the
work of each person is in that person
and they have a right to do it
and this education we're talking about
it it raises up young people who are
prepared to live a fully human life
raising their own families making their
own living influencing their own
community
and that's it let me ask Dr O'Toole I'm
a Young Senior Citizen and so I won't
see my grandchildren flourish at your
age I won't know how they do are you an
optimist or a pessimist about American
Education I
rough time right now I think covid has
been really rough on teachers I think a
lot of great people have left the
profession
and I think that that was for many
people the final straw in a long you
know difficult time
but think about the Silver Lining
parents all over the country are now
urgently concerned with what their
children are learning in school they're
rediscovering the fact that they're the
primary educators of their children
children are
being held accountable by their parents
I speak as a former
School principal who was always always
always trying to get even these really
involved Charter School parents more
interested in what we were teaching so
that they could help you know at home
and so I I think that
I think that we're seeing with
individual families and I think that
we're seeing
you know in recent election results too
school choice is becoming a big issue
for people and I think that bodes very
well and I think common ordinary
Americans can be counted on to love
their children it was the best of times
it was the worst of times applies to
American Education right I'm so excited
about Arizona West Virginia and Iowa and
Ohio by the time we do this next year
Ohio and and Iowa will have joined the
ranks of backpack funding yeah so that
six thousand dollars goes out the door
you can now tutor you could learn the
classical education you can go down to
Arizona and you can open up a tutorial
for 10 kids and get sixty thousand
dollars and run that yeah and that's
amazing be good at doing it and enjoy it
and let's see the accountability if you
do that will be where it belongs the
parents will decide if the kid comes to
you
you see and that means that better be
good at it you better know what you do
you better have a curriculum you better
be in touch with Hillsdale right yeah so
let me conclude tonight by thanking Dr
Atul and Dr Ahn and every one of the
tens of thousands of you have been
listening let me remind you that the uh
Charter School initiative at Hillsdale
begun by Steve Barney with Dr iron
poking his finger in his chest oh those
many years ago goes on through the
generosity of tens of thousands of
donors large and small please become one
of them call Triple Eight four three
seven thirty nine forty one Triple Eight
four three seven thirty nine forty one
or go online to hillsdale.edu town hall
please stay on the line if you didn't
have a question answered if we didn't
get you into the queue because we're all
somewhat loquacious then just stick
around and leave a message and we will
get back to you with that and I want to
conclude by thanking you for your time
tonight for watching for listening Dr
O'Toole it's always a pleasure to be
with you Dr on it's mostly a pleasure to
be with you and and uh we'll do it again
next year and will have four states to
talk about and then eight states and
then 16 States and mayor curriculum's
flourish and spread
thank you good night friends